هي اللغه ذاتها
كالا صدى هنا لاحاديث السلام بين اشتباكات
وقصف وانفجارات توزعت ساعه يوم جديد من
عمر محنه السودان
تلك يوميات السودانيين الموعودين بواحده
اخرى من هدن المتحاربين الهشه
تتوقع دوائر استخباراتيه غربيه معارك
طويله الامد في السودان لان الطرفين كما
تقول يعتقدان ان بامكان كل منهما الانتصار
عسكريا وانه ليست لديهما دوافع تذكر
للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
نحو ذلك التفاوض تدفع جهود مجموعه دول
الرباعيه وجامعه الدول العربيه والاليه
الثلاثيه لذلك فهي تبارك الحراك الامريكيه
السعودي الذي اثمر قبلا عن هدن تبادل
المتحاربون في السودان الاتهامات بخرقها
والان تنبثق عن تنسيق الرياض واشنطن
محادثات اوليه هي الاولى من نوعها تجمع
ممثلي كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
يقول وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان بلاده تامل ان يقود حوار
الطرفين الى انهاء الصراع وانطلاق العمليه
السياسيه في السودان
ويضيف الوزير السعودي ان استضافه
المباحثات السودانيه هي نتاج تكاتف دولي
وجهود حديثه مع الولايات المتحده وبشراكه
مع دول المجموعه الرباعيه والاليه
الثلاثيه
البيان السعودي الامريكي المشترك بشان بدء
المحادثات السودانيه كان قد حث الطرفين
على الاخذ في الاعتبار مصالح الامه
السودانيه وشعبها والمشاركه بنشاط في
المحادثات نحو وقف اطلاق النار وانهاء
الصراع كما دعا الى مواصله تنسيق الدعم
الدولي لعمليه التفاوض الموسعه والتي قال
انه يجب ان تشمل جميع الاحزاب السودانيه
والى ضروره ضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
قوات الدعم السريع رحبت بالبيان واكد
قائدها محمد حمدان حميدتي في تغريده على
تويتر ما قال انه موقفه الثابت بضروره
الوصول الى حكومه الانتقاليه مدنيه تؤسس
لتحول ديمقراطي كما اشاد حميدتي بالجهود
الاقليميه والدوليه المبذوله للوصول الى
وقف اطلاق نار يسهل فتح ممرات انسانيه
يتفاعل الجيش السوداني هو الاخر بايجابيه
مع محادثات جده لكن ناطقا باسمه قال
للجزيره ان تفاوض سيشمل قضايا عسكريه
وانسانيه ولا علاقه له باي قضايا سياسيه
نحن اعلنا عند انطلاق وفدنا او مغادره
وفدنا الى جده ان هذا الوقت ذهب
وسيناقش الجوارب التي تتعلق بالهدنه بما
يتم تنفيذها لتحقيق او لخدمه الاغراض
الانسانيه بالمقام الاول وان يكن فالقوه
المدنيه الواقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري في
السودان تامل في ان تقود المباحثات الى
وقف القتال ومعالجه الاوضاع الانسانيه بما
يمهد لحل سلمي سياسي مستدام بيان تلك
القوه حث القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
على اتخاذ ما دعاها قرارات شجاعه تنتصر
لصوت الحكمه